yeah hello and welcome to this video the
Blitz game again after a bit of a break
but yeah let's let's play some blitz
games I didn't have basically any
content on the channel
in recent weeks have been busy with some
things but also I was kind of yeah I
wanted to do something on the channel
but I felt I should have some kind of
yeah concept ready for what to do I
didn't just want to do do do blitz games
do other things rather but I couldn't
quite make my mind up what to do and I
still haven't so I really want to do
something more on the channel but I am I
tend to yeah over let's say organize and
plan those things I'm more the sometimes
you're sitting there and that okay much
what can I do and this and that and at
the end yeah I'm doing not much at all
and I decided to instead of just yeah
hesitating what to do on the challenges
to put out some content I know that the
Blitz videos are still very well liked
so I'm going to do some and ever lots to
do some other things but it will not be
like a big restart of the channel that I
thought about like yeah dude you know
get a logo or whatever this game is kind
of funny because I'm winning the Queen
after it moves yeah
well it's a it's a neat little opening
trap that yeah that white fell into him
and the Bishop f5 line it's relatively
new addition to the Queens gambit
accepted
yeah Queen B three years one of the
possible moves and the big revelation
was that c6 now is actually completely
fine for black Bishop f5 was never
played in the pre
computer error but now the engine shows
that actually 20 xb7 is not a good idea
due to Knight b6 and here and white is
already in huge trouble the Queen is
already out of squares and I think the
only move that at least gives some kind
of game from what is e 6 that is some at
least breaking this idea however it is
still not great I'm not quite sure what
its best stockfish gia wants to take on
C form yeah that looks like it looks
pretty strong actually if your if you
check this I could take and then Queen
c7 I guess yeah and the Queen is still
trapped so white has to do something
really funny - yeah to get the Queen out
so like this this and now probably can
not be 595 or something but him this at
least was clearly better for black if
you have a pretty pretty good position
here got the bishop pair and I have got
two pieces yeah first of all against the
rook and the pieces will be strong 97 95
b6 that is good for black like roughly 1
pawn and stockfish evaluates it yeah
still this is a lot better than there
should be three after which the Queen is
immediately trapped
so the first blitz game after a bit of a
break is an eight move win that's funny
okay guys thanks for watching